it's an honor to have you guys here now
you guys you just threw this together
this little number what is this from
your new album what is it for you man
this is just for me just for you this
sounds pretty good now now uh let me get
this straight
stephen's stephen's going to be playing
a beer bottle
really yeah he doesn't have a drum so
he's playing you're going to just give
me a little sample that's a light beer
bottle however right that's good it's
early in the morning
what are you going to do
you're just going to play like that that
takes talent i'm telling you man it does
who's this guy who joined them with the
uh you know what is this gentleman's
name you play clarinet yep what's your
name my name is leo chilipo perry yeah
let me just see if this echo thing is
working on your mic let me hear that
howard do you like that
do you think that's too much is it too
much or two no you got it man all right
here they are porno for pyros doing it
live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they couldn't do it i ran down the road
with no shoes and no jacket
here i go dive away
[Music]
watch me dive away
[Music]
it's
[Music]
now i know young boys
don't think it's matter
to be
a genius give me a lover that won't give
me trouble
some sexy dreams that you want these
bubbles here i go dive away
[Music]
watch me dive away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i
smell the bleach
[Music]
[Music]
now here
[Music]
[Music]
watch me dive away
is
[Music]
it up
[Music]
oh man that is nice
you